also leute ganz ganz wichtig ihr müsst
bei sun machen und dann schön mitgefühl
die kugel hier oben drauf legen und dann
funktioniert das auch keines ist sie
zwar manchmal muss man diese hose
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video sollte ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut heute ist es
soweit wir machen den nächsten part von
ich teste die genialsten amazon gadgets
für euer zimmer ist da eigentlich
scheißegal ob er jetzt ein eigenes
zimmer hat ob ihr euch das mal mit
irgendwem teilt ob ihr auch schon
erwachsene seite und der frau aber so an
sich kann man glaube ich mit den
produkten was anfangen egal wie alt man
ist das letzte video war so ein label
reaction tut mir auch leid aber heute
packen wir die ganzen sachen ausland
angekommen einige coole sachen habe ich
bestellt und ich würd sagen wir laden
gar nicht lange lassen auf jeden fall
super gerne doch nach oben auch wenn es
euch gefällt und letzte auch so mit
welchem paket fangen wir an ich würde
sagen lasst uns mal hier mit anfangen
oder übrigens ich habe die ganze zeit
versucht diese nachbar zu erreichen der
meint akin hat dir das paket schon
gegeben meinte dagegen wir am samstag
gegeben oder so weil ich dass das fehlt
noch was
aber das ist auch schon wieder so hier
haben wir schon mal leute und wenn die
musikbox ich würde sagen vielleicht doch
mal ganz ganz kurz
das lassen wir wenn ihr den ersten part
nicht gesehen habe und gerne auch mal so
eine grobe info über alle produkte haben
wollt check das erst mal ab aber ist
auch eigentlich nicht so wichtig wir
haben hier die music angel wieting
bluetooth speaker also eine schwebende
music box die man sich ganz entspannt
langguth muss nicht ins zimmer sein was
noch mal sagen levy taping heißt es
nicht so leidet im moment asiatischen
aktien habe ich das ausgesprochen ok
also das ding hat glaube ich so 60 euro
kostet oder so das gibt es auch eine
teure aber ich hab mal das günstiger
wahrgenommen
wir packen das mal aus eigentlich ist
dass das produkt auf das sie am meisten
geheilt bin weil es halt irgendwie mit
magneten schweben kann hier haben wir
glaube ich schon mal diesen bluetooth
speaker ladegerät und dann hier diese
dinger meinst du ehrlich man kann die
jetzt so drauf legen und die schwebt wie
krank habe ich noch nie gesehen soll ja
ich weiss nicht muss ich wahrscheinlich
erst mal aufladen oder das gute ist wir
haben ein langes kabel dabei weswegen
das sicherlich schnell möglich gemacht
werden kann auch super nett egal wo man
ist ob in amerika england oder sonstwo
obwohl england weiß ich nicht aber du
hast für alle steckdosen einen adapter
leute schaut mal dieses alle kabel ist
für diese fliegende untertasse hier und
das andere kabel wahrscheinlich für den
speaker dh man kann dass dinge nicht mit
rausnehmen also die style kann man
wahrscheinlich aufladen für die
untertasse braucht man allerdings immer
strom macht ja auch irgendwie
okay das ist schon mal an
aber wir sind hier gar nicht am strom
also braucht man braucht man doch nicht
unbedingt strohmann scheint ach so dann
auch warum leute gut dass juri dabei ist
sonst würde ich das wieder in den
kommentaren immer einen wenigstens
einmal doch über der alex zu tun also
leute ganz ganz wichtig ihr müsst bei es
an machen und dann schön mitgefühl die
kugel hier oben drauf legen und dann
funktioniert auch weil sonst für die
nämlich angezogen und die dreht sich
sogar ich weiß das muster musik drauf
das ist so krank dass er den finger und
durch es wackelt auch ich puste war
louis geile sorry sicher auch jetzt bin
ich nur mal gespannt auf die
soundqualität weil er halt cool wenn die
neiße
sonst ist bisschen blöd aber 60 euro das
müsste eigentlich klar geben so suchen
wir mal die box music angel hier
ok wack und connected also super
einfache bedienung eigentlich ich bin an
sich begeistert jetzt machen wir einen
song an
ich habe mein lieblings von juli will es
machen
fans dürften mit dem einst war das jetzt
schon die lauteste stufe okay leute also
schaut an sich nice ist jetzt nicht
brutaler weist reicht auf jeden fall um
gut laut musik zu hören eine sache die
ich jetzt gern noch immer kurz nach
lesen würde das ding kommt auch aus
schen sind glaube ich bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher aber man kann es auch
bei amazon bestellen also alle links
sind auch wieder in der video
beschreibung natürlich verlinkt hier
steht jetzt wenn man lange auf diese
komme man wenn man lange auf diese lampe
hier drückt kommt irgendwie noch so ein
ganz bestimmtes licht jetzt stecken wir
jetzt mal
jetzt haben wir unten auch noch immer
schaut mal hier unten
jetzt wechselt das hier auch noch das
nicht sieht eigentlich aus wie ein ufo
ne also eher mäßig wochen einmal das
licht ausmachen und ich kann weil ich
jede keinen schlaf und später ging es
steil und ok sonst wäre das hier noch
geklemmt das video kriegen was einmal
drehen
okay es ist auf jeden fall ich würde den
dingen zehn von zehn sterne geben
5 von 5 gibt's 19 10 punkte auf jeden
fall also ganz kurzes fazit vielleicht
wenn jetzt leute fragen lohnt sich das
ich würde sagen eigentlich schon also
ist schon leisten wenn man jetzt eine
neue musik box brauch oder so und mal
was anderes haben möchte gegen das
dingen auch was den preis angeht ich
habe da jetzt nichts auszusetzen also
gefällt mir mega gut ich würde sagen wir
kommen aber weiter zum nächsten patch
etwa ein bis jetzt haben wir noch heute
aber viel mit led und so aber das ist ja
zurzeit auch total angesagt deswegen
let's go next ich glaube ich weiß schon
was das hier ist genau das habe ich auch
bestellt hier ist dieses depot fonds
liegt also einschlafhilfe mit diesen
dingen kann man wohl innerhalb von acht
minuten oder wie auch immer das kann man
wohl vorstellen einschlafen das würde
ich dann gleich mal testen wir können
das mal kurz aus packen wir haben jetzt
gerade nachmittag soll kann nicht meinte
ich könnte jetzt auch schlafen ist
schwierig deswegen nicht packt das jetzt
mal aus und dreht das dann heute abend
für euch reicht das natürlich
direkt rein also wir haben wir erstmal
beschreibungen noch eine beschreibung
und das ist auch schon das neue logo das
bin ich ja gar nicht gewohnt batterien
sind dabei es gibt es ja gar mehr das
lesen des handbuchs fünf minuten erhöht
ihre wahrscheinlichkeit des einschlafens
so ok und jetzt na ja also wir gehen
jetzt dann mal in mein zimmer und
checken das ab und testen dann halt mal
ob ich damit wirklich schneller
einschlafen kann ich bin gespannt los
geht's okay leute wir sind jetzt hier in
meinem zimmer ich habe mich dazu
entschieden seinen kleinen mittagsschlaf
vielleicht zu machen also ich mache das
wirklich öfter mal dass ich so 16 uhr
von 16 bis 17 uhr einfach mal eine
stunde schlaf
das hier ist das ding und ich glaube ich
habe es noch gar nicht erklärt das
sendet so lichtimpulse an die decke und
man muss die atmung an diese impulse
anpassen wenn das nicht aufgeht sollte
man eine art und wenn es wieder zugeht
ausatmen ich habe jetzt den acht minuten
modus aktiviert indem man einfach einmal
drauf drückt und ich lege das ding jetzt
mal da oben hin
das sollte auf jeden fall reichen ich
seh's deutlich und dann werde ich mich
mal darauf konzentrieren und versuchen
einzuschlafen und leute ohne scheiß wenn
es nicht funktioniert sage ich euch das
auch also ich sags euch so wie es bei
mir war ich weiß dass wenn ich mich
jetzt hier nachhaltig schon hingegen
würde ich einschlafen würde und ob das
sammeln das schneller geht checken wir
mal
[Musik]
wir müssen das jetzt aus
täger so ich glaube ich habe eben zu
lang mit der kamera gelabert jetzt aber
jetzt muss ich mich konzentrieren
[Musik]
leute das geht also kurzes fazit ich bin
nicht eingeschlafen bin ich ehrlich auch
nach acht minuten nicht vielleicht muss
ich diese 20 minuten variante machen ich
bin allerdings wirklich sehr sehr müde
geworden ich glaube das lag daran weil
sonst hat mich viel schneller ich habe
viel langsamer geatmet also ich kann mir
gut vorstellen dass es funktionieren
wird bei mir wenn ich 20 minuten lang
mache genau also soviel kann ich dazu
sagen ich denke dass es wirklich helfen
kann und mehr gibt es nicht aber wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
leute herzlich willkommen zurück ich
würde sagen dass war doch wenn es
interessant wir kommen jetzt zum
nächsten gadget was ich euch noch gar
nicht gezeigt habe ich hatte mir das mal
bestellt und wir müssen uns hierzu auch
noch kurzen videoclip anschauen damit
ihr seht wie das funktioniert und was
ist voll mist weil ich muss sagen ich
finde es eigentlich genial ist das paket
drin wird ein kurzes video ab let's go
[Musik]
also ich glaube es ist am besten wenn
ich das jetzt einfach noch mal kurz
erklären weil bestes video dazu gibt es
eigentlich nicht es ist eigentlich ganz
einfach wir haben hier drin eine led
lampe die man unter die decke klemmen
kann und dann zusätzlich mit dem handy
steuern kann du kannst musik darüber
steuern da ist ein bluetooth box wohl
drin und du kannst halt die farbe ändern
irgendwie 16 millionen verschiedene
farben was weiß ich genau ob wir die
jetzt unter die decke hängen weiß ich
nicht wir werden sie auf jeden fall
anschließen dann werde ich euch die hier
auf dem tisch präsentieren und erstmals
auspacken irgendwie ist das so eine
entschuldigung musikbox unboxing hier
auch so ein bisschen mit dass dinge
kommt aus also auch von amazon also die
haben wir das produkt hat man auf jeden
fall schon ziemlich stylish aus ist
allerdings brutal leicht ja genau und
das ist da jetzt hier so ein bisher ist
kein problem aber man hat jetzt keinen
stecker sondern halt diese lampen
zugänge das heißt wir müssen das jetzt
erstmal anschließen und da ich da jetzt
nicht der talentierteste drin bin dauert
das wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weswegen
ich kurz pausieren
okay leute ich hab das ding jetzt hier
so halbwegs installiert also hier ist
jetzt strom drauf das ja das wichtigste
fragt mich besser nicht wie es gemacht
hat ohne juli war das wahrscheinlich
auch erst morgen
und jetzt muss man sich hier aber ich
bin schon connected kann ich denn jetzt
schon auf jeden fall muss ich meine
aktien aus dem app store die heiß teilen
und damit kann ich das jetzt wohl
steuern aber okay
und du kannst jetzt hier wirklich alle
möglichen farben wählen im juli film
einmal die app ab also du kannst das
turnier so rum ziehen und dann wechselt
das halt immer die farbe die hier
einfach so drauf kommen dann kann es
jedoch so verschiedene modi verstellen
rede im rainbow jetzt wechselt immer so
ein rain beruf haben das licht
anscheinend puls und jetzt bin ich auch
mal hier auf die musik gespannt warte
wir nehmen einfach mal irgendwie was
habe ich denn
irgendwie kriegen die musik hat nicht
darauf jetzt haben wir es her dass es
irgendwie keines ist
manchmal müsse man diese hose wenn also
der ist besser aber das geht auch gleich
glaube wenn wir oben darunter hängt so
für eine deckenlampe kann man da nicht
mehr kann ich muss sagen es ist ein
bisschen kompliziert so die app zu
steuern dann die weil man muss sie so
doppelt mit bluetooth koppeln damit
überhaupt das funktioniert wie es
funktionieren soll da habe ich jetzt
gerade wieder so zehn minuten daran
herumgefummelt trotzdem glaube ich schon
dass wenn man das ding unter der decke
hat kann es eigentlich nicht sein ich
kann jetzt auch nichts gegen sagen also
feiere ich eigentlich fürs bad bears
auch gut stimmt romantisch bisher rote
licht und so na ja gut dann würde ich
sagen kommen wir zum letzten produkt
märz gedacht es ist wieder ein led chips
naja ok zu guter letzt haben wir einfach
nur hier dieses mini dinge und mini
led-lampe works amazon alexa google wurm
geht eigentlich ziemlich schnell meine
das müsste eine 720 und gewesen sein
genau können wir einfach hier in die
drinks tun und dann mal steuern
dann kann alles hier farbe machen bald
ist alles voll mit farbe hier sehr gut
aber er gut ich mache hat mal eben auf
also in dieser lampe ist an den
bluetooth dinge drin oder wie es das
weißt du dass leute ist es leider ein
problem aufgetreten in diesem ding hier
ich habe das jetzt mal entfernt wir
haben so eine fassung nicht das voll
komisch das ist eigentlich eine 720
fassung hier oben war so ein stab drin
aber das kann man eben nur ein drehen
und irgendwie sind wir jetzt ein
bisschen aufgeschmissen also ich würde
das dann halt im nächsten unboxing mal
kurz testen wenn ihr mir da in den
kommentaren helfen könntet also an die
technik hat er euch wäre das super wie
ich denn diese lampe an kriegen hier
kann man das ja glaube ich ganz gut
sehen
das ist halt ein bisschen doof und wenn
ihr dann irgendwie ein trick hab
schreibt gerne in den kommentaren
solltest du nicht sagen ich hoffe es hat
euch mal wieder gefallen lassen dann
nach oben monierte auf jeden fall den
kanal für weitere coole test videos es
macht mir unfassbar viel spaß und wir
sehen uns dann am donnerstag spätestens
wieder gibt es ein neues video
haut rein